[Musica]
le coste del mediterraneo si dividono in
due di partenza e vi arrivò però senza
pareggio più spiagge più noti di imbarco
di quelle di sparco toccano i tagli a
meno vite di quante salirono a bordo
a sparigliare il conto la sventura e noi
parte di essa
[Musica]
ci sono luoghi dove il bisogno di
violenza è molto più forte della volontà
ci sono ore in cui il bisogno di
violenza è molto più in alto della
volontà
vivo con prudenza
come un buon mercante in un grande
affare
più spesso come i topi sento la mia
ombra fra i muri
scivolare
[Musica]
scacciati dalla terra siamo il semi
sputa turi più lontano dall'albero
tagliato fino ai campi del mare
servitevi di noi piacimento di vita da
sfruttare pianta metall umani molto più
di una forza da lavoro siamo deserto che
cammina popolo di sabbia ferro nel
sangue calce negli occhi
[Musica]
potete respingere non riportare indietro
e cenere dispersa la partenza noi siamo
solo andata
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie per avermi invitato ho deciso di
fare questo mestiere un po per caso
faccio fotografia in realtà cerco di
raccontare delle storie 20 anni fa mi
piaceva fare delle fotografie
fotografavo i fiori le bacche e i
paesaggi e andai in america a
fotografare il grand canyon il monumento
harley è però nel tour organizzato c'era
un giorno in cui andavamo a tijuana che
la prima città del messico
adesso c'è un muro vent'anni fa non
c'era un muro ma era molto facile
entrare in messico ed era molto
difficile ritornare in america c'era un
mi ricordo un cancello enorme con delle
maglie e molto distanziate e la prima
visione che b
da piccolo borghese ventiquattrenne fu
di guardare un messicano mettere la
testa dentro queste maglie ed è ridare
america e rimasi folgorato e poi tijuana
c'erano le prostitute a un dollaro a
mezzogiorno e io me lo immaginavo invece
di notte nei viali delle città e vidi
una realtà che per un ventiquattrenne
piccolo borghese fu un po troppo forte e
deciso di raccontare delle storie decisi
che le fotografie di paesaggio non mi
interessavano più decisi che l'uomo era
molto più interessante da raccontare che
il paesaggio per tornare al video che
abbiamo visto nei fotografica abbiamo
visto sono fotografie diciamo sto
portando avanti questo progetto dei
migranti da ormai cinque sei anni
abbiamo visto un piccolo delle piccole
serapo l'azione di un lavoro che ho
fatto nel sahara occidentale per un
lavoro fatto sul popolo saharawi dove
oltretutto sono stato sequestrato dalla
polizia marocchina e rispedito
gentilmente a casa e poi abbiamo visto
nel 2013 era interessato moltissimo
questa cosa che la l'alba dorata che è
partito di estrema destra greco era
terzo partito in grecia e sapevo che i
migranti che stavano ad atene venivano
malmenati e avete visto probabilmente la
fotografia di coltellini che hanno
ferito
i migranti poi c'è stata c'erano
dell'ecografia ventimiglia scattata
l'anno scorso ma il grosso lavoro è
stato fatto nella rotta balcanica quasi
un anno e mezzo e sono partito in realtà
nel settembre 2015
sono partito per un'urgenza di vedere
con i miei occhi che cosa stesse
succedendo perché era una una migrazione
epocale ne parlavano tutti i giornali
telegiornali e io in quanto reporter
leggo ascolto però poi sono curioso e
quindi devo andare a vedere oltretutto
era a 500 chilometri da casa mia
e i miei figli studieranno questa
migrazione epocale per cui ho detto devo
andare a vedere con i miei occhi avevano
chiuso il muro in ungheria nel settembre
2015 e tutti i migranti si erano
spostati a trovarmi in croazia sono
arrivato con la macchina e ho visto
8.000 e 10.000 persone messe nella
stazione buttate per terra aspettando il
treno che li portasse in austria e come
tutti i reporter come tutti i
giornalisti inizi a scattare scatti
scarti scatti scatti scatti scatti a un
certo punto
non lo so se lo se lo faccio solo io
spero di no veramente però io mi chiedo
perché sto a fare questo non avevo
assegnati di giornali era andato per
curiosità
quindi mi chiedevo perché sto facendo
queste fotografie
sto aspettando che accada qualcosa come
il laboratorio che poi fa lo scoop
fatto sta che io faccio sempre questo
esempio quando racconto questa storia a
me mi sembra sempre di stare allo zoo
dietro delle sbarre nella parte libera
tra virgolette e guardare una scena in
quel caso i migranti stare dall'altra
parte delle sbarre bellissimi perché
sono bellissimi sono molto fotogenici
migranti come un leone quando vai allo
zoo l 1 è bellissimo e tu scatti le foto
poi se ti avvicini un po togli le sbarre
riesce a far capire che magari non non
sta in gabbia e quindi è una finzione
ho visto tantissimi giornalisti
tantissimi report che stavano lì a fare
milioni di scatti e quindi le prime i
primi due giorni di scatti a trovarmi ho
fatto delle fotografie orrende tutte
uguali senza una motivazione fino a che
a un certo punto ho deciso di andare
alle boe e ho assistito a tantissimi
tantissimi sbarchi e a un certo punto
mentre stavo aspettando che succedesse
qualcosa ho riconosciuto una bambina che
stava ho riconosciuto ho visto una
bambina che stava piangendo e scendeva
dalla barca e mentre stava per scattare
ho riconosciuto mia figlia io non ho
scattato
mi è caduta la macchina per terra e ho
iniziato a piangere come un deficiente
faccio questo mestiere da 20 anni ho
visto diverse cose sono stati in
cambogia mine antiuomo eccetera
quando ho visto mia figlia ho avuto
venti minuti di breakdown totale
però ho capito che se mi ci riconoscevo
io se potevo dare un nome a quella
bambina
forse era quella la chiave di volta per
raccontare i migranti
chiudo con una frase di erri de luca non
avete sentito varie varie frasi che è
stupido chiamarla gente ma sono persone
una per una
grazie
[Applauso]